ذكرت صحيفه فاينل شيلتايمز نقلا عن مصادر
الدبلوماسيه ان موجه من الاستياء تسود دول
الاتحاد الاوروبي
بسبب النيه الاتحاد فرض سقفا لسعد الغازا
ووفقا للصحيفه فان المانيا التي تتزعم
معرضه هذا القرار ترى انه سيعود بالضرر
على الاتحاد وحكومه دوله وان فرض سقف لسعر
الغاز لن ينهي مشاكل الوقود في اوروبا بل
سيعود بنتائج عكسيه وخيمه على السوق فيما
تعتبر دول اوروبيه اخرى ان هذا زواجها
قادر على كبح اسعار الطاقه التي وصلت الى
مستويات قياسيه هذا العام ما ادى الى تضخم
وتفاخر المعيشه
مناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفي دكتور محمد
سيف الدين في العلاقات الدوليه اهلا بك
سليمان العضو السابق في حزب المحافظه
البريطاني اهلا
بكمين واسم حالي ان ابدا من لندن معك يا
استاذ راتب والصدر
او سقف سعر الغاز الى اي مدى هذه الخطوه
يمكن ان تكون ايجابيه خاصه وان هناك
خلافات عميقه داخل دول الاتحاد الاوروبي
بخصوصها
طبعا مساء الخير لكم ولي المشاهدين الكرام
اا طبعا كبح كبح اسعار الطاقه او وقف
الغلاء هذا الشيء مفيد للمجتمع في كل
انحاء العالم يعني الان من يدفع الضغط
الضريبه ليس الحكومات يدفعها المواطن
الاوروبي والمواطن
الامريكي وكل الناس هم الذين يدفعون
فواتير الغاز لذلك خفض اسعار الطاقه او
وقف الحد الاعلى
للاسعار هذا من صالح المجتمعات جميعا لان
المتضرر الوحيد هو المواطن الحكومات طبعا
ستلاقي بدائل اخرى وستحاول همم ان تجد همم
شيء اخر يعوض لها هذه
الخسائر ولكن المواطن هو الذي يخسر ويدفع
دوما ضعف السعر هو اتوقع هذا سيكون جيد
بالنسبه للمواطن الاوروبي اجمالا
ومحمد صحيح
يعني تحديد سعر او سقف سعر الغاز دكتور
محمد هل تعتقد بان هذا الحل كما تفضل ضيف
بالاشاره لانه فيما بعض الدول الاوروبيه
تذهب بهذا الطرح كما تفضل استاذ راتب دول
اخرى تتزعممها المانيا تقول بانه بالعكس
هكذا طرح هو سيونك الحكومات سيعطل
الامدادات سيدخل همم الاتحاد الاوروبي
ودول الاتحاد في مصعب اكبر واثقل ما رايك
اول مساء الخير للجميع نعم اعتقد ان
الموقف الالماني والموقف الاسباني ايضا
هما موقفان دقيقتين دقيقان بهذا بهذا
الشان تحديد سقف للاسعار لن يؤدي ابدا الى
توفير المعروض من الغاز وايضا لن يؤدي الى
خفض الاسعار بل سيؤدي الى ارتفاع الاسعار
والا عكس ما يطلب من هذه الاليه السبب في
هذا الموضوع بسيط جدا ويتعلق بابسط قواعد
الاتصال عندما تؤدي سياسه دعم حكومي او
سياسه تحديد سقف اهو للاسعار همم الى همم
نقص في الامدادات سوف تبحث سوف يبحث
المستوردون سوف يبحث المستهلكون عن هذه
الامدادات في السوق السوداء وبالتالي فان
حاجه اوروبا من الغاز سوف لن تكون مؤمنه
بشكل مستدام وعلى المدى الطويل حتى الان
لا يوجد بدائل للغاز ولكن دكتور محمد
لماذا حظرتك
تحديد سقف سعر الغاز بالامدادات وتعطلها
لو تفسر لنا اكثر او تشرح لنا اكثر هذه
النقطه
لانه نعم لان جزء يعني اوروبا كانت تعتمد
جزئيا على الغاز الروسي حواء يعني بمجمل
منطقه اليورو وكان تعتمد حوالي 40% على
الغاز على امدادات الغاز الروسيه الان مع
تنامي يعني مسار الحرب في اوكرانيا ومع
اشتداد وطاه هذه الحرب طبعا اصبح هناك
يعني تقليص لهذه الامدادات ومن المرجح انه
اذا تصاعدت عده هذه الازمه عن يتم وقف هذه
الامدادات بشكل كامل يتم تعويض المعروض من
الغاز الروسي عبر عده وسائل ابرازها الغاز
الصخري الغاز المسال الذي ياتي عبر
الشحنات البحريه وبالتالي وبالتالي هذه
الشحنات يعني تحدثت فرنسا منذ شهرين عن
انها تدفع اربعه اضعاف السعر الحقيقي
لامدادات الطاقه من دول الشمال ومن
الولايات المتحده وبالتالي البدائل غير
متوفره البدائل الكميه غير متوفره
والاسعار ارتفعت بشكل كبير جدا منذ بدء
الحرب في اوكرانيا الان نتحدث عن حتى
العام 2026 كل كل المعروض من عقود العقود
البعيده للغاز الصخري تم بيعها بشكل شبه
كامل وبالتالي نحن نتحدث عن ان هذه الاليه
المراد منها هو شراء هذا الشتاء فقط
وبالتالي الهاء الشعوب ودفعين ضرائب في
اوروبا وفي العالم الغربي بان هناك اليه
يتم البحث فيها وهي الاليه اذا اردنا
تقويمها ربما تقترب من الوصف الذي تحدثت
عنه الوزيره الاسبانيه همم حين قالت انها
اشبه بمهذله لانه همم عرض غير واقع يعني
يقترب من ان يكون عرضا غير واقعيا
وبالتالي هو ليس لا يقوم على اسس العرض
والطلب المعتمده في الاتصال
هل ترى بان دول الاوروبيه تراهن على ذلك
تراهن كما قال الدكتور محمد على محاولات
استماره المواطن دون قراءه لعواقب قد تكون
متوسطه او طويله المدى قد تكلفها الكثير
كذلك من وراء هكذا
طبعا لابد ما تتكلف الحكومات مشاكل ومصعب
ولكن الحكومات تنظر للمدى الطويل المدى
الطويل ااا روسيا يدخلها يوميا ما يقارب
500 مليون دولار من الطاقه من الغاز وهي
كانت المصدر الاول لالغاز لالمانيا ولدول
الاوروبيه ولكن الان في هذا الوقت لا
يريدون ان تدخل الخزينه الروسيه هذه
الاموال يريدون ان يحددوا لان هذه الاموال
سوف تذهب همم للحرب في اوكرانيا لذلك
الاتحاد الاوروبي وامريكا سيحاولون قدر
الامكان تحديد الاسعار والتوجه الى مصادر
اخرى للطاقه من دول اخرى مثل قطر مثل همم
الدول العربيه
ايجابيات طويله المدى او استراتيجيه طويله
المدرسه تعتمدها او تفكر فيها على الاقل
دول اوروبيه في حين انا بعض هذه الدول
الاوروبيه تقول بانه همم هذا القرار همم
ان يكون هناك سعر محدد للغاز سيكلف
الحكومات اكثر مما تحتمل بمعنى انه اولا
ستفتح المجال للشركات والافراد للتعامل مع
الغاز بطريقه ليس فيها همم
استراتيجيه منهجيه همم سيكون هناك صعوبات
في الامدادات وهذا ما ذكره الدكتور محمد
منذ قليل سيكون هناك تضخم اكثر مما تعيشه
اليوم فااا هل هذه بدايه الخلافات كذلك
داخل الاتحاد الاوروبي تعتقد
نعم ولكن هذه الدول لا تنظر للمصلحه
العامه تنظر لمصالحها الخاصه هناك طبعا
خلافات بين الدول الاوروبيه لان كل دوله
اوروبيه تنظر الى مصلحتها ومصالح شعبه
ولكن للمدى البعيد المصلحه هي واحده عندما
تنخفض اسعار الطاقه ويكون المواطن همم
مرتاح لذلك فهذا جيد لجميع المواطنين همم
الاوروبيين اما اذا كانت المصلحه همم
المصلحه للدوله فقط فان ذلك سيؤثر عليها
ممكن لسنه ستستفيد لسنه او اكثر ولكن
للوقت الطويل ستكون هي الخاسره لان
الاسعار سترتفع مره اخرى
وسترتفع سترتفع وهذا
سيؤدي الى ارتفاع الاسعار والمواطن سيكون
طبعا همم من يدفع السعر كما قلت سابقا
لذلك غلاء الاسعار لا يفيد الح ابدا في كل
دول اوروبا وفي العالم غلاء الاسعار هو
دوما مضر للمواطن ومضر للدوله ومضار
للجميع لذلك تحديد الاسعار فيه شيء ايجابي
وسيكون المواطن همم لديه
القدره على دفع فواتير الغاز ولديه القدره
على همم شراء المواد لانه الان يتكلف همم
ضعف
هذه الفكره منذ قليل صحيح الدكتور محمد
همم انت منذ قليل تحدث عن انه بالعكس هذه
الطريقه
لمحاوله اللاعب بعقول المواطنين بالقول
بانه نحن سنحاول همم التخفيض من مستوى
التضخم ولكن هذا لن يكون او ستكون تداعيته
على الاقل الاقصى على الحكومات وعلى
المواطنين فسر لي اكثر لانه وظيفه يقول
بانه بالعكس هذه الدول ستقترح مثل هكذا او
ستدعم مثل هكذا قرار همم لمصلحه المواطن
اولا واخيرا وليس لمصلحه حكوماتها
نعم اولا نحن متفقون بشكل كامل على انخفاض
اسعار الغاز في فائده لكل المستهلكين على
مستوى العالم وخصوصا للدول الاكثر قدره
على يعني الاكثر يعني الدول الناميه
تحديدا هناك فائده لهذا الامر لكن ما
نبحثه الان هو تاثير هذه الاليه فيما لو
اعتمدت على اسعار الغازات انا ما اقول في
هذا السياق بان هذه الاليه اذا اعتمدت سوف
تؤدي الى ارتفاع كبير جدا في اسعار الغاز
وبالتالي الى زياده معدلات تضخم وبالتالي
الى انهيارات اقتصاديه تبدا بالدول القدره
في الاتحاد الاوروبي وتنتجه لتؤثر على دول
الكبرى وهذا يعني عمق الموقف الالماني
والموقف الاسباني همم بالنسبه لتاثير هذه
الاليه على روسيا يجب ان نسترجع بعض
الاحداث يعني سنوات الخمس الاخيره روسيا
وقعت عقدا مع مع الصين ب 500 مليار دولار
حوله توفير يعني توفير امتداد غاز على مدى
طويل منذ منذ فبراير شباط الماضي وقعت
اربعه عقود هادوق مع الصين والعقود الاخرى
هي مع الهند ومع ايران وبالتالي ما يعني
ما وقعته وما اتفقت عليه روسيا في خلال
هذه الحرب يفوق بكميات كبيره ما كانت
تورده لاوروبا وبالتالي تاثير هذا الامر
على روسيا خصوصا مع الاخذ بالاعتبار
ارتفاع الاسعار هو امر يعني بالتاكيد غير
موجود بالعكس ما يؤدي يعني ارتفاع الاسعار
يؤدي الى زياده واردات الخزانه الروسيه
المستفيد الوحيد مما يجري بحثه الان بهذه
الاليه هو مورده الغاز الصخري وتحديدا
الولايات المتحده لانه كما قال ضعفكم
الاستاذ راتب انه على المدى الطويل سوف
تعتمد اوروبا على هذا الغاز وبالتالي سوف
تبني المنشات المؤهله لاستقبال هذه
الوردات نتحدث الان عن موانئ اوروبيه في
دول الجنوب موانئ ضخمه جدا وتكلف
استثمارات كبيره جدا بالاضافه الى ذلك
محطات تغويز اي اعاده تحويل هذا الغاز الى
الى الحاله المساله الى الحاله الغازيه
وبالتالي نحن نتحدث عن صراع على من يكون
المورد الاساسي للغاز الى اوروبا لكن بعين
اختم بهذه الجمله الان نعم الاتحاد
الاوروبي يخاطر برفائه يعني ينتحر من اجل
ان ينقل امدادات الغاز من روسيا الى
الولايات المتحده ومن سيدفع الفاتوره هو
مواطني الاتحاد الاوروبي
يجب ان يختم بها ونفهم كذلك مستقبل هكذا
قرار على الاتحاد الاوروبي همم استاذه هل
كما يقول ضيف في هذا القرار همم يكون
بمثابه انتحار الاتحاد الاوروبي لان بعض
المراقبين يتحدثون عن انه ليس حفره فقط
هذه خلافه عميقه وهذه بدايه تفكك الاتحاد
الاوروبي
لا اعتقد ذلك لان مهما تكون الصعوبات في
الاخير سيكون هناك حل طبعا ستواجه هذه
الحكومات صعوبات في البدايه
لكل ازمه لها صعوبات ولكن في النهايه في
المستقبل البعيد ااا ستكون طبعا هذه
الحكومات مرتاحه جدا لان الاسعار همم ستقف
عن الزياده والشعوب تستطيع ان تدفع
الفواتير لان هناك ملل كبير كذلك من
التململ من الشعوب الاوروبيه اجمالا
بالنسبه لاسعار الطاقه الان الشعب لا
يستطيع ان يدفع سعر الفاتوره والان الشعب
الكثير منهم لا يستطيع ان همم يكون بيته
دافع لذلك اعتقد ان الدول الاوروبيه
قرارها صائب وسليم بالنسبه
للمستقبل البعيد اما في المستقبل القريب
طبعا سيكون هناك صعوبات وهي ستواجه هذه
صعوبات بطبعا بتوجه اخر ستحصل على الطاقه
لما يمكن ان يطرح اذا كان سيمر هكذا قرار
ام لا غدا سيكون النقاش ربما ستكون هناك
مصادقه كما تقول بعض التسريبات على هذا
القرار ان مره طبعا بالاجماع من دول
الاتحاد الاوروبي السبعه والعشرين شكرا
لكم جزيلا الشكر الدكتور محمد سيف الدين
باحثين في العلاقات الدوليه ومن لندن راتب
سليمان العضو السابق في حزب المحافظ
البريطانيا شكرا لكم